on this episode we talk location
Location Location how I celebrate
victories and what to get your mama you
ask questions and I answer them
[Music]
this is the askgaryvee
sheddeth
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 93 of the ask gary vee
show really excited only 7 episodes away
from episode 100 we just had a morning
meeting I think we decided yes we
decided that we're going to tape it on
tape it we're going to record it on
Monday the 18th coming here Monday the
18th in New York City at 4:30 we've
created a Facebook RSVP invite that is
linked below in in the Facebook post
let's make sure we do that and in the
YouTube and I will tweet it we want you
here in New York City this is the time
to cash in on your miles this is the
time to throw three of your homies into
a car and do a road trip this is the
time to get to New York City meet up
with other vayniacs during the day you
guys do your thing your big boys and
girls but at 3 p.m.
either in a park like we did an episode
what was it do we know if we don't know
here's it all right
got some dudes together for today's show
so somebody just jump right in let's get
right into it your name Kyle coming Kyle
say hello to the vaynernation everybody
and and if it's raining or something
crazy we'll do it here at Vayner and so
vaynernation i would love to see you in
New York City March 18th for 30 episode
100 will line up everybody and we will
just roll we will QA our asses off on
askgaryvee episode 100 Ovie's are the
names 14 names give me your hat
Stefon you know little warriors have
these are the 14 people that correctly
guessed what their favorite football
team the person they would draft I'm
gonna pull one name you will then email
India love it India what's your email
address
great you will email India if you're the
winner no weird stalker people hitting
up India to like do this pic my pic my
question don't stalk her you'll be
eliminated permanently from the
askgaryvee show
so the winner gets a jersey now I don't
know if rookie numbers I've bought a lot
of rookie number jerseys in my career I
would recommend everybody here have us
buy it for you in late August once that
number is firm rookies tend to change
their numbers and campus players get cut
and you don't want to be rolling around
like I am with a lot of jet players with
the number that doesn't match what their
actual number is and the winner of the
contest for the jersey from me to you
from your favorite team based on the NFL
Draft is oh by the way this person
heartbreaker for you this person you
were almost the person but it slipped
and this person won so bad news for
Blake Jameson which is tough because I
know Blake good dude sorry bad news
socks right and the winner is
Anthony denardis let's let's clap it up
guys big ups and buddy you know India
Congrats wait a minute over here it is
Oh from YouTube Anthony big winner
Congrats
I like these contests I think more
contests are in our future India let's
get into the show that bottled grapes
asks we have a brick and mortar shop in
today's technology world how important
is location location location location
location location so I think you know
the 1998 version of me would have said
oh it doesn't matter as much anymore in
20 years ten years there'll be all EECOM
as the gray hairs have come in I
recognize things take longer to evolve I
would say location matters tremendously
still today and very much over the next
10 years do I think 20 years from today
that we will be in a 30 40 50 60 70 %
econ world and things will be overpriced
by location in a physical world
I do but I would say for the next half
decade to a full decade location is
still enormous ly important people still
go to stores people still drive their
cars people still are in dense areas
where a great location really matters
and so I would highly recommend
respecting the bricks and mortars
location now that being said there's a
more interesting variation of this
answer which is today's technology world
are you able to just rely on your bricks
and mortars location location location
and that is a big fat no if you are not
thinking about your EECOM your mobile
strategy or app culture your content
strategy your social strategy your
digital strategy you are just basically
setting the the game plan in motion to
the demise of your business and so
locations that matters but the
investment into the future especially
with the acceleration and exponential
growth of our culture around digital
behavior is an enormous mistake so you
need both that I highly believe in who
needs that room what I do that's fine
I'm finishing my show all right good
Anthony asks is standing your ground
during negotiations something that is in
someone's DNA or can it be thought
Anthony I I think it is probably a very
strong combination of both I for a long
time up until July 7th 2014 believe that
almost everything was DNA but something
that does not come natural to me is
taking care of my health right and what
I've done is I've hacked and I've taught
myself and now is it my own behavior no
it's I have a babysitter his name's like
you've seen them you've heard of them
so I do think certain things can be
taught to a degree meaning for example
I've been playing basketball more often
and my jump shot is getting better I've
brought back my running jumper Stefan
knows what I'm talking about and so and
so I do think negotiating skills is
something that can be taught but it
would be it would be naive to not
recognize that some people are just born
with that talent so probably like every
answer to every question in the world
the answer is both a little bit of
training and building up I think I
taught AJ to be a better negotiator I
think he naturally had it in him but I
think there was some teaching moments
there at the
garage sales of New Jersey and so I
think I actually think the way could be
taught is more through osmosis I think
surrounding yourself with those kind of
strong negotiators is better than
watching a video about it or reading
about how to do it and so I think
learned behavior by feeling it not just
by reading it is the way to go so I
would say both I would say 8020 I think
80% of the equation is natural but I do
think you can be taught 20% lift off of
where your natural place in the lexicon
of negotiation or maybe anything else
really is Dimitri asks how do you
celebrate victories Dimitri I took this
question for a very specific reason
because this is absolutely no question
one of the flaws of my my being I am
terrible at celebrating victories it is
actually quite sad in some ways if you
decide to look at it that way or a very
strong winner's mentality which is how I
like to look at it but the truth is I
stink at it as a matter of fact one of
the bigger flaws that I think I'm
creating at vaynermedia as a culture is
that we don't celebrate our wins we land
big new accounts we grow like crazy we
want awards hush-hush nothing
no no chest pounding and I think it's
interesting because when you look at me
as a character and you look how I roll
for all the humble bragging and the
outright bragging and the ego and the
confidence that I spew out there my it's
funny it's always in hindsight and it's
in showmanship it's not in reality
meaning I celebrate victories poorly for
example the New York Rangers and the New
York Yankees both won championships for
me they won her championship I was very
happy for about a couple of hours no
parades no next day taking off and like
soaking it in I won and I moved on and I
stopped caring I'm gonna say it here
first
I really never said this out loud
outside of my family I am completely
convinced that the New York Jets win a
Super Bowl before I buy them that I will
no longer like the Jets that much and
all my energy will then be transplanted
100,000 percent into the New York Knicks
I firmly believe that I just completely
believe that and so I love the client
I I celebrate victories in a very soft
non appropriate way I'm really
disappointed in in the way that I
celebrate victories it's something that
I want to work on because smelling the
roses is an important part of growing
and living and it's just not something
I'm good at
Cory asks what should I get my mom for
Mother's Day Cory I think the big
strategy for Mother's Day 2015 is for
people that are watching this show to
recognize a lot of their moms are on
Pinterest and that they should go to
their mom's Pinterest board and see what
mama has been pinning and buy her
something from there and so if you're
not lucky enough to have that where your
mama is pinning then I would highly
recommend looking at her social media
and looking at what she's tweeting or
facebooking which will not be as good as
Pinterest but you might find a diamond
in rough and then if you can't do that
the move that so many don't do that I
highly recommend for you and the
vaynernation
is to randomly call your mom's best
friend the one that you might have not
talked to in a long time or might be
your aunt that you only talk to like
once a year to wish a happy birthday or
whoever it may be and ask her what or
him what they should buy your mom
because friends know and I think that
would be thoughtful I think putting in
the effort to try to really buy your mom
something she wants for Mother's Day is
the move I feel like that I've inspired
three or four of you because that's
about as high as I think this will go
but that makes me happy because three to
four of your moms are gonna have a
better Mother's Day because of the
askgaryvee show dr. Julie asks as
vaynermedia continues to grow what is
the one thing the company has done to
keep the culture hungry doc everything
stems from the top my hunger level is so
intense it's crippling and so because of
that the culture continues to be hungry
because I will suffocate the culture to
allow nothing else to creep in no
complacency no celebrating the victories
allows you to stay really damn hungry we
haven't accomplished
[ __ ] yet and so yeah we're the fastest
growing social digital agency ever and
yeah we're unstoppable we're great and
all this but we haven't done anything
that I'd like to accomplish yet which is
I don't know to win the whole goddamn
game to like make every single client
every single employee every single
agency in the game recognize we are the
best and it's disrespectful to even
allow yourself to think that you can
compete with us and so you should really
focus on being number two does that
answer your question
all right good show I like that I was
tight that was tight yes it was
thoughtful
today was tight question of the day how
do you celebrate victories as I'm trying
to work on myself to make myself better
maybe your comments will help me and
give me some ideas don't come up with
bullcrap don't say oh I go on vacations
or buy yourself something nice just to
give me advice I need you to tell me the
truth what do you do to celebrate
victories you keep asking questions I'll
keep answering them
Monday the 18th get your ass to New York
I don't want to see people tweeting
today tomorrow and be like oh I'm
definitely gonna come and then when I
look you didn't make it if you want to
be here you'll be here figure it out you
can walk she can say location I know
[Music]
Abbott freaks me out super into it
rubbing off on Gary well all-black India
[Music]